Oh what is going on YouTube should I try
something you know recently a subscriber
asked a really interesting question hey
Emma dude I was wondering how you felt
about kids being really spoiled that day
do I believe that kids are spoiled
nowadays hell yes I do you don't if you
want go ahead and [ __ ] like oxygen we'll
see y'all that y'all shall receive you
already know what it is LG hot tub baby
let's get it next out it's 2012 and you
[ __ ] kids on spoiled ass but
that's what I'm talking you can you
spoil this hell but guess what I don't
blame you I'll blame your parents that's
right parents I'm putting my pledge is
finger and all your bad parents out
there to my knowledge most sugar don't
have jobs which means they don't have
money which means that they don't have
control of what they possess so what
they have is basically what is given to
them a few weeks ago I said you know I
saw this five or six year old carry a
cellphone what the [ __ ] you need a
cellphone for baby what the hell is
going on in your life at the age of five
that you need to contact somebody
immediately hey donkey sweat I [ __ ]
myself game why the hell do kids get so
much [ __ ] for their birthday nowadays do
you know what I got for my birthday
grown up I got life [ __ ] life that
won't [ __ ] that I already had happy
birthday David you could do leave
another year more importantly just
throwing [ __ ] at your kids just to shut
them up what you should do is teach them
the value of a dollar
do you realize what would happen if I
had a six-year-old that told me that
they needed an iTouch daddy I want an
iTouch over what was that you wanna
touch keep it up you want to get a I
don't get [ __ ] for Christmas do you know
what happens to spoiled kids
y'all don't learn [ __ ] newsflash little
[ __ ] most kids do not get what they
want
the moment they ask for it you know
what's gonna happen to you you go go
into the real world that starts to
realize that oh [ __ ] I got a body
with my own money when I was a kid and I
wanted something I had to go work and my
parents beauty supply store and I
believe that everything how hustle boy
had that much more value in it because
early I can't believe I sold weaves in
living with the help
see I believe will really make somebody
spoiled is more along the lines of if
they're really unappreciative of their
position in life and how they carry
themselves in all seriousness we're
gonna go ahead and talk about the
subject I'm gonna go in and share a
little bit of peace about my life a job
when I was a kid I grew up Pro appeared
in the story when we first opened the
fun business I remember we couldn't even
afford shelves to put the supplies on
that we wanted to sell they were all on
Cockrell boxes but here's the funny
thing despite my economic status I never
really thought I was poor and this is
the reason why I think my parents were
so amazing you see what my parents did
was made sure that I believed that I had
everything that I needed and what I had
was already more than enough kids thing
my parents gonna buy me the best toys
and games but at the end of the day the
values that they instilled in me are
worth a million times more than anything
they could have bought me as a child so
all you kids out there that are
fortunate to have all the things that
you want be appreciative of it and make
use of it and for your parents step up
the game because we all know that you
work hard for your money and family just
make sure that your kids know it too
all right yeah money in my pocket I get
money on the flop on the floor I let it
wish drop it off in then we're gonna
snow mom no no no it's no no no yo
yeah yeah
hey y'all checking if y'all want to see
McDonald's spokesman in China you have
it right here BAM but you don't wear yet